[MUSIC]
He
always surprises me Ever since I first saw him skate, it
's been a series of surprises
[MUSIC]
Kyanihime Novice
happy child right?
I've leaked a little bit of functionality, so I jumped to the sand dunes today with a beret
that didn't look like it.
He also overwhelmed the free skate with his astounding strength. He won the
Grand Prix Final five years in a row. Viktor, the living legend of Russia,
had great winds.
It was a
spectacular skating and about Yuri Katsuki, who made it to the Grand Prix Final for the first time this time,
I wonder if it was Honda.
Date
: I'm serious about pie
My name is Tatsuki, and I'm a Japanese figure skater who's been everywhere since I was a
kid.
I want to move to Detroit and do my best.
Five people
watched the TV
public viewing.
Teru
good
From next year we'll go up late at night, we won't need two Yuri People who don't have
talent will retire quickly Ahhhhh
[Music]
Talented young people will keep appearing even if I'm
not here Katsuki  Please, it's too early to retire I
haven't decided yet, so don't rush ahead
What are you going to do after graduating from university?
I don't want to think of new
There is a sound even if the pitcher doesn't put eye oil
Ellie
Commemorative photo
Yes
, yes, that's fine. It's
difficult to
say that you can meet the person you've always admired on an equal footing with 100.
What an idiot, what a piroshiki tearful Grand Prix Final
[Music] It
's been 5 years since I've come back to a
broken station It's been an elevated ceremony at a fragile station Wow
[Music]
This is the
advantage Minako-sensei Hiro's first time
Arthur as a powder here I guess
I can't miss the information that Minako-sensei is regulating.
So I lost
, I'm shy, everyone who supported me just because they were
from my hometown  However,
the culmination of the first half of the season, I lost to rags at the Grand Prix Final, and while I was still trailing the damage, I lost to
Pooh again at the All Japan Championships
.  I've dissolved the relationship, looked at my worries, and for the time being I've put restrictions on it
.  I was doing hi betting
Next time I'll say hello to everyone who is ignorant
Minako-sensei Is the ballet class good
today?
I'm
sorry, but I'm tired, right
? Yeah,
everyone wanted to see
me.
Continuing from the Ranpuri Final, he continues to win the European Championship in tons of sweat and resources
, showing his unchanging good form.  The men's free will have a feast before 7:00 after this
.
I'm sorry I couldn't come back for 5 years I'm sorry I didn't come back for 5 years I'm sorry
that this is my opinion at the graduation ceremony I'm
not going to eat katsudon that's Yuko and Seta Toran
Minako-senpai doesn't change even if he drinks alcohol
Yuja Eiki When we met  I've been thinking about you for a while, but
all 9 of you
are just like your mother
.
I'm going to eat a lot of
katsudon tonight.  Before, Oto suddenly left Ryonan and went to college, but what are you going to do now
?
Kyushu is frustrated
A castle town by the sea The
castle is not based on historical facts The castle is a ninja house inside The
hot spring inn that was the only tourist resource is steadily collapsing And all
that's left
is our utopia for a month After
all, the hot spring at home is
empty  After the 2nd group, I wanted to leave the engine for a while.If only
Yuri could show up, I'd ask him to show me the player's hotel
room.I won't tell you.
Bio 5 is cheap, but it's the
final run
No, Mr. Onda, this is an unexplored area.
I'm sorry, I'm going to practice a bit
Nice to
meet you 2
I'm sorry.  You've skated alone,
I'll protect you,
yes  Thank you
Yuu-chan is a ringmate two years older than
me When I was a kid, I didn't really skate, so she was someone I admired Madonna, who broke the
ice castle She's
still cute,
amazing
goo Goo,
don't get in the way Dave Ken-kun
New arrival  You can't bully a child, right? Boob Day
Victor in Roshu, Kisoji, World Tree, and the silver medal with the highest score ever My
cool mother
[music]
I wish I could live I have a Victor poodle
oh
Piccard's Hanare
Eh, Yurika is also a poodle  When I started raising him, my
name was Victor Big.
I really like pixelated things.
Look at me, I'll let
you know in April All
three
[Applause]
Hata Aroi
[Music]
Hey there
We've prepared four quads for this program.
Quadruple Kirei Market The
second one is the Great Spirit scene in cooperation with Victory.
The guys who go out all over are not ashamed to show off their sex appeal It
seems like everyone is drinking too much
[music]
me
[applause]
Don't come with a maiden
like that, you're so handsome  No
[music]
[applause]
Police trip
[music]
yeah yeah yeah [music] pass in 4 times none
renard
please do more
But I'm tired of being depressed, so I've been thinking all along
that I want to regain my love for skating,
and imitate Yu-chan and Victor, and remember when I did everything.
The world figure skating championship men's single winner is a tournament golfer
Russia's stick should be shaved Poropoo Please give me your resolutions for next season
Yu-chan's pumpy Angel rape I haven't seen you in a long time
That's the version of retiring Hey, come on, it's
dangerous,
notice All three of us are fans with an advantage
Nishigori only Kussara
If you want to practice, come anytime
It's a
lily, I've left this town for five years,
and I've been thinking only about skating.
Yuri Puri Snow Key is finally
starting full-scale for
senior participation Reverse book imo jump once more About to enter the era of the top two in Russia with fellow student Victor Futaki Golf
It's the same expression,
I'm around
Gyugun Katsuki
Umeyuri My child uploaded a video and
added a lot, but now my chest is still being
said
na na na
I've been retweeting piano videos all the time, but
Kazuki-kun  What do you think about Marle, are you stupid? In
Japan,
there was a sudden cold wave in Kyushu, and the cherry blossoms were in full bloom.
Ah, what is this? Even though
it's already April, I cut off the news because it's troublesome to contact
you
.  I'm in the
hot spring now I
'm anoano
ban
[music] Yeah yeah yeah
Why are you going here?
[music]
He was a genius who always amazed me
me
[music]
tee
me
[music]
b 4
me
[music]
yeah yeah yeah trip [music] Oh effect 0 together  It's going to take Russia It's going to break, it's going to be a break-up No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!